oh man Captain America with a green
slash Blue Lantern ring unstoppable I
would agree with that what's up guys
we're not supposed to start for like
another eight minutes so I'm just gonna
chill hang out with you guys oh man Wow
tons of people oh man yeah officially it
doesn't start for eight minutes but I
guess since I went live we already got
people showing up what up fans you know
right now the thing is on like the chats
on slow mode I wonder what would happen
if I took off no it's not on slow mode
it's on regular mode okay cool see I
wonder what would happen if I took it
off slow mode and I can't figure out how
to put it on slow mode anymore
there's managed moderators man oh hey by
the way um those of you guys who don't
know there is an artist named Ethan Van
Sciver
who is probably one of the best artists
in comic books right now he draws like
Hal Jordan the Green Lantern Corps
you guys like he does these live streams
where he teaches you how to draw comics
and it's super cool it's really awesome
um actually I should link that and the I
should link that in the video or in the
live stream Ethan Van Sciver either man
Sciver drawing I like how it says then
all right yeah I don't know if anybody
will see that nobody's gonna see the
chats go too fast all right here let me
update the description
Ethan Van Sciver Channel
there you go okay if you guys just want
to like update the subscription then you
guys will see that his link is down
there it literally says Ethan Van Sciver
channel so uh okay Sam the greats - what
would you do if a guy comes up to you
and asked to be your avocado a man wife
I have no idea what that means
[Laughter]
Steve Steve Stifler that's awesome what
about the Infinity Gauntlet part eight
where is it can you finally answer this
since I of the Infinity Gauntlet part
eight had to be taken down because of
copyright issues rest assured I'll be
going back and recovering all the
Infinity Gauntlet videos I'll be
updating them in my current style so you
will get Infinity Gauntlet part 8 rest
assured do not do not worry
um okay uh let's see Matt B well we ever
get a video for some of the classics
like zero hour I've thought about it but
I mean I wouldn't really see a reason to
do zero hour crisis in time maybe
because how Jordan tries to kill the
whole DC Universe I have no idea maybe
um I'm not sure I mean maybe we could I
honestly I never really gave it too much
thought in terms of doing like zero hour
crisis sometime I mean zero hour was
never really like a big story I mean it
wasn't this sense it was kind of cool
cuz I counted down backwards um though
three guys who don't know one of the
biggest things about zero hour crisis
sometime is that after it was finished
it gave fans this kind of like like
two-page spread about like the origin of
when things happen so like in this year
Superman arrived on earth in this year
battery Nell Bruce Wayne became Batman
it was actually pretty cool in terms of
how it all in terms of how it all
happened um okay uh the the tails beat
you I guess hopefully I pronounced that
right I love your work thank you I
appreciate that you know thank you for
the ten dollars I really appreciate that
um Justin Clark yo Rob has anyone ever
told you you sound like Neil deGrasse
Tyson
all the time usually it's you guys but
people tell me that all the time so I
appreciate that it's he's a super smart
guy I could only ever hope to be as
smart as Neil deGrasse Tyson but he is
he's a really cool guy have you guys
read his book what is it it's
astrophysics for people and people in a
rush or something like that
I can't remember off the top of my head
um okay so alright let me answer a
couple of non super chat questions first
and then we'll jump into the super chats
who do you think would win
superboy-prime yes I think super warp
Ron would win against himself oh man um
let's see how can Wolverine heal is out
of mantium you can't Wolverine will you
cannot heal from his own adamantium
that's the whole idea of all man Logan
is he keeps getting older and his
adamantium is his adamantium doesn't his
adamantium basically keeps administering
poisons in his body so it wears down his
healing factor Red Hood vs. flashpoint
Batman I want to say Red Hood I want to
say Jason Todd but I'm but I don't know
I mean Thomas Wayne seems like he'd be
pretty beast so seeing him in action I
don't know
I mean he's you know he's like that was
one of the coolest things alright uh
Logan owl Albert I think it is hey Rob
big fan got a question how much do you
know about Marvel's forget-me-nots he's
my favorite and I would love if you
covered a video covered him in a video I
actually don't know much about him I
know that he's a mutant with the ability
to make everybody forget that he exists
and so that's why nobody remembers him
but that's really all I know I've never
really done any research on
forget-me-nots for one I could tell he's
like an omega-level character just
because he can make everybody forget his
existence but I don't know how
far-reaching his powers are I don't
really know too much about that alright
Omar Santana Rob not comics related but
you have any favorite hit hip hop
artists current or ever most def and
common those are two of my absolute
favorites when it comes to hip hop and
Talib Kweli which black star with mos
def
that was definitely a pretty solid thing
um let's see
do I play WWE 2k no I don't I've thought
about it but no I don't I don't play it
ever to be 2k pickle rig versus Hulk
hoax never gone on a rampage as a pickle
so pickle Rick definitely wins dudes a
beast hey Rob can have eaten power
escalate
yes that was a Grant Morrison creation
back when Grant Morrison took over the
x-men in 2001 with new x-men which fun
fact Grant Morrison was writing he was
writing a whole bunch of things at DC at
the time he'd written Doom Patrol he had
done the flash when Mark Waid took a
break
he wrote JLA the revamped version of the
Justice League after the various
endeavors to try to do justice league
international and justice in Europe and
so on
anyway Marvel was recovering from the
comic bust of the mid-90s an
editor-in-chief Joe Quesada brought him
over from DC and had him revamp the
x-men so he changed their outfits
different things like that introduced
the romance between Emma Frost and
Cyclops but one of the things that he
introduced was a secondary mutation and
it was the idea that a mutant will have
a power but if given enough time and if
put under certain kinds of duress that
power will basically escalate that power
will expand and it'll become something
more and so he that's what he gave like
Emma Frost the diamond the ability to
turn into diamond that was her secondary
mutation the funny thing about that is
their secondary mutation didn't
initially emerge as somebody correct me
if I'm wrong it didn't initially emerge
until he is for extinction I think it
was the first story arc that he did with
new x-men and then it was the death of
all the mutants of Genosha
when Cassandra Nova just like kill them
all and she emerged with negasonic
teenage warhead and she basically was
she was diamond and so that's where her
secondary mutation came from um let's
see uh so was Morrison's x-men good yes
it was
Morrison's x-men was extremely good it
was it was probably one of the most
groundbreaking x-men runs of all time
and I would say it's second only to
Chris Claremont run but Chris Claremont
wrote the x-men for 17 years so how do
you compare a 17-year run to a run that
lasted a you know less than five so
there's a lot that that went on there um
bushy-brow zero zero zero for the month
of february will you be doing any more
content towards black panther who is the
black panthers story no I've not covered
any uh no I have not covered that and
yes I will do black panther stuff in
February
usually what I try to do on the month
when a movie comes out I just try to do
like a huge dump on that character or
team wouldn't that movie releases so a
Wonder Woman I did a lot of Wonder Woman
stuff or as much as I could get away
with anyway before people stopped caring
like Thor we're gonna do a ton of Thor
stuff we're doing Dan Jergens run-up to
the death of Odin and then going into
Ragnarok and then we're going to do or
starting from the death of Odin up to
Ragnarok then we're doing J michael
Straczynski 's run after Ragnarok
running all the way up through fear
itself and everything so like we're
gonna cover a ton of Thor stuff you guys
are gonna know everything there is to
know about Thor by the time I get down
with you
Geron versus the DC Universe who is
cheering alright someone tell me who
this guy is because I don't know who he
is and people keep asking me that all
the time
they keep asking about jiren and I'm
like who is Jaron alright I watch to see
I haven't watched geek Tim's videos I've
not watched his videos as much as I
should have
and I saw your question I need to do a
video with Danny um I have not watched
his videos as much as I need to
mostly because he blew me off at
WrestleMania and y'all can tell him that
when you guys get it because you would
tweet him out and say Rob says he won't
collab because you blew him off at
WrestleMania so because of that actually
he didn't he and I just got super busy
and we didn't get a chance to meet up um
but we need to myself and geek and we
definitely need to meet up but no I
don't know who Geron is so people keep
asking me about it but I don't know who
cheering is so I guess I need to know
what do you think of the Black Panther
trailer oh okay here's the deal man as
excited as I am about like Black Panther
I'm more excited about Michael B Jordan
as Erick Gill monger like I am I'm more
excited about him because Michael B
Jordan man would tell you some dude that
guy ever since I saw him and bow wire
when he was a kid and he was playing
dude he was in that show he is a
standout actor he's incredible um I'm
really excited about him I think I think
he's gonna be an incredible villain I'm
disappointed because I think Marvel is
gonna kill him off which sucks because
I'd really love to see him come back but
I am really excited about the trailer it
looked it looks pretty amazing um Jared
pon pon Xia I think that's how you
pronounce it hey Rob my daughter's just
getting into Batman and the bat family
what are some good stories to start on
sliders run start with the new 52 court
of owls knight of owls and just go from
there just get I don't do detective
detectives not that great new 52 but
just get new 52 you Batman and just have
a read forward from there
fair warning some of the stories can get
a little dark when you get to death of
the family when you get to in-game those
stories get kind of dark and the robbed
Court will tell you man they get pretty
dark oh man okay um ray Henry hey do you
know anything about what happened with
Nate gray and the current Marvel
Universe no clue he's not been
referenced once there's neither hide nor
hair of him so my guess is as good as
yours um do Lucifer I would love to
because I think the first story arc in
Lucifer is like like supposedly he
killed God so I'm I think it'd be kind
of cool I would definitely love love to
check that out okay what do you think of
a fight of Ghost Rider versus Etrigan
the gone gone the form of man rise the
demon Etrigan um I don't I don't know
Ghost Rider I think would win but again
I'm not that familiar with Etrigan so
I'll probably have to do some research
to be able to give you a real answer on
it alright doll the non super to have
people we will answer your questions
um I figure if somebody's gonna give me
cash that I should you know I should
definitely answer their questions so I'm
trying to I'm trying to catch trying to
get to each of these um who would be
able to control the storm in mule near
would storm be able to control the storm
among Amelia as far as we know yes my
assumption would be yes she is she's
been able to control cosmic storms the
problem is that storm is on an insane
level it's a storm that was capable of
obliterating entire you know I guess
solar systems or entire areas of the
universe so I can't tell you for certain
my answer would be yes that'd be my
knee-jerk response but I can't tell you
with any measure of certainty um let's
see who will win in a fight maestro
hooker or doomsday my stroke I would
think um I would love to see my stroke
win but I think doomsday might keep
coming back
maestro Hulk is smarter than regular
Hulk I mean if it was world breaker Hulk
you know definitely he would win
maestro Hulk don't know because as far
as I'm aware my show is not as strong as
row breaker so ah the red samurai when
will you do a Elseworlds exchange maybe
talk about Justice League Unlimited or
Justice League mortal for when Justice
League movie comes out
I'd love to do an Elseworlds exchange
but the schedules of myself and Sal are
crazy busy so usually whenever they do
it I don't necessarily have a chance to
do it um but I would definitely love to
so all right okay so for the guys who
were doing super chat um you know I'll
answer your questions but I try to go
back and forth so that people you know
don't feel left out if they don't have
the means to do super chats so Darryl be
when what will what do you think about a
runnin the accuser solo movie about his
days as a Kree general honestly Ronon
was never really that interesting to me
at least the way he was done in
guardians of the galaxy - didn't really
I didn't really enjoy it or gardens of
the galaxy one rather didn't really
enjoy it too much
um I think it would be interesting and
it might it might do well but I don't
know I mean I'm kind of on the fence
about it I might check it out you know
I'm not a hundred percent sure about
that um okay DC the new frontier I mean
it's great you know it's a great movie I
didn't watch the I want to read the
comic so but I've heard is really good
so Jaron is more powerful than beerus
okay so that's okay I feel like some
Dragon Ball super fan out there just
losing their mind and you're just like
okay I mean you know he's strong really
bears uh well i cover mr. miracle well
it's not done yet but it is an amazing
story so far I really want you that
might be one of those videos cuz I don't
expect a video like that to do really
well that might be one of those videos
where I just pepper alongside something
else like I just double stack it with
something else that you know I think
well you know that will do well so um
okay uh we didn't we need to do a couple
of these super chairs Oh Danny Garcia
just give me five bucks well I
appreciate it Danny
thank you that is appreciated D less I'm
better educated about comics because of
you Rob thanks superboy-prime vs. world
breaker hulk world worker hulk wins
super what prom is cool but he ain't
world breaker Hulkster I don't I don't
know though I take that back maybe
Superboy prom would win that would take
some thinking I mean that would take you
see the problem is that we haven't seen
they've never fought each other they
never had a reason to you and what
they've done doesn't line up it'd be
different if world breaker Hulk like
killed everybody then that would be a
whole different whole different kettle
of beans
but like I mean we don't we don't know
that that he would be that powerful so I
have no idea maybe he would I I have no
clue all right uh message retracted okay
they took their message away out comics
explained uh wow we just got a ton of
super chance Franklin Richards vs. Goku
you guys were all about okay I'm gonna
hold off on the vs questions for a while
because you guys are all about the
versus things I don't know Franklin
Richards with a power he has could
probably just face Goku out of existence
and that would be the end of that um and
this seems like it would be pretty
pretty straightforward uh I mean that
would be my thing okay
robbed this from sire New York Rob when
will you cover the issue where the Hulk
knocks the things rocks off what I
didn't even know that happened all right
I need to look that up where he knocks
the rocks off his body is that what
you're talking about cuz like I would I
need to check that out alright the
terror of death five bucks thank you hey
Rob I was wondering if you could please
cover dc1 million is my favorite Grant
Morrison story yes it's in the works I
definitely had that on my schedule when
I'll get to it I'm not sure kids getting
pushed back but it's definitely on my
schedule Danny Garcia can you explain
the hierarchy of the DC Universe gods
aka the new gods and the old gods in
relation to the DC heroes yes I was
thinking about that the other day
actually that was running over that and
I was like I should cover something
along those lines so I definitely will
I'll definitely grab that alright uh
Scotty Robb who is powerful enough to
beat high fathers and dark sides father
you VidCon also can you do a DC Comics
explain on him I have no idea who would
be more powerful to defeat him I mean
he's of the height like he's the highest
of the Gods so I don't know or heist of
the old gods anyway I I haven't I
honestly have no earthly clue um what
are you going to finish vision also
ready for Imperial X yes I'm ready for
Imperial X it's gonna be solid
uh I thought I finished fission I'll
have to go back and double-check what's
good good way good and cheap way to
order and read comics for both DC and
Marvel cheap graphic novels calm I
believe is a really good website that's
the one that Dave used to use from the
weekly pool if you guys remember him um
Jeff shifflett rumor has it John Kent
will become superboy-prime how would you
feel about it okay
for those of you guys out there who are
not familiar with this and Benny was the
one who told me about this Benny over at
comics story and there is a crossover
happening this winter that will feature
Superboy Superboy and I think it's like
the super sons of tomorrow and in the
story that we saw it was this vision
Superman had of fighting his own son and
the on running theory is that Superboy
will become superboy-prime that the son
of Superman will become superboy-prime
so um I think it'd be kind of cool you
know to see his son become Superboy prom
I think that'd be kind of Awesome um
okay uh so some non non non super chat
questions because I want to make sure
these guys get some attention they get
some love how can I buy a Rob chorong
there was currently not a place for you
to buy one yet I'm trying to get a place
figured out but there's not a place for
you guys to buy one yet um let's see
what about okay Goku is awesome but just
gives too many chances I mean he likes
to test people man Franklin will beat
him in an instant well it depends
because Frankel is not a terrible person
either I imagine their fight would be
more of a conversation than an actual
fight please do the walking dead Walking
Dead is coming back when the show comes
back on because nobody watches it when
the show is off the air uh hey Rob what
are you going to continue DC Universe
history since it's been almost a year
and you haven't done part two people
weren't interested in part 1 so I just
kind of said okay you know and just sort
of called it a day maybe I'll go back
and revisit it but I mean that didn't
really seem to be a whole lot of
interest for it so I don't know um let's
see uh let's see please do a DC's The
Spectre video uh he's actually on my
list of Omega beyond Omega level
characters so the spectre is definitely
there um
Kentucky is home it is to a degree I do
miss it I I do definitely miss Lexington
um okay uh let's see
all right uh Andy stone um Rob Canadian
Rob we're here from the committee from
the Canada branch are you going to cover
any of the new old man Logan stuff you
know that I've been covering that we're
current the only thing that we haven't
done is the one where he fights Maestro
Hulk and the Hulk family but work her on
everything else that's in the Wolverine
playlist uh
Jim Jim Kosei I guess it is hey Rob new
to comics here we read injustice
darkside war
some new 52 Batman so far can you
recommend a starting point for DC
rebirth read Green Lantern's if you want
to get in a Green Lantern continuity
read Green Lantern's um that one is
definitely one of the absolute best I
also have a huge play list for the DC
reverse-flash is also a really solid one
Rob Corps from Kentucky represent really
like what part of Kentucky are you from
also would could world war hulk be
beyond omega level no because he's not a
universal threat he's just a planetary
threat so he's not he's not powerful
enough
um let's see you please give us this is
eric coachman please give us a story on
superman family and do a story on aoa
what's a Oh a I don't know what a OAS
I've no idea what that is what happened
to rob explains I know about the PC gave
me Fiasco I just want to reason from
your mouth oh no I just got tired of all
those crazy gamers and [ __ ] like that
really I was like okay we're done like
if they're gonna freak out over
something that's stupid then I was like
whatever um but I may just revamp it and
turn it into like a vlog channel or
something along those lines um I don't
know I may just kind of does it you know
delete it entirely and just go with
something else I have no idea um let's
see hey Robbie boy will you ever come
back to the superwoman and new Superman
and the other Superman family characters
yes I've been mean to do that I don't
mean to get back into them
I love new Superman and I love
superwoman on the super woman runs
actually coming to an end I think that
DC is getting rid of it
I know that DC does have a cancellation
coming up and it's the first
cancellation of DC rebirth and it was
actually huge news I can't which one it
is maybe it's superwoman I'm a member
off the top my head um but if it is true
I'm gonna be disappointed because
they've had one heck of a track record
more of our usually canceled stories
like they're really six issues and if
there's no pre-orders we'll just cancel
it like that let's be like we're done
you know and just call it a day so it's
it's kind of a it's kind of weird can I
talk about Legion again what do you want
to talk about Legion Legion with I don't
know what you want me to talk about WoW
Madra $30 holy cow I've heard the Joker
Batman is supposed to explore the idea
of a bat man who killed Joker but it
turns out who kills him becomes the
Joker could the Joker Batman and metal
be from Killing Joke
in a universe where he did kill him I
have no idea but that is an amazing
theory where Batman actually killed the
Joker at the end of The Killing Joke and
comes the Joker um okay Age of
Apocalypse okay cool I would definitely
be down with that like that would be
pretty solid um yes I would love to
cover that that'd be pretty awesome that
would definitely be one of the coolest
things do you think Aquaman in the
Justice League trailers seems kind of
book accurate I don't know and I don't
care because he is amazing I don't care
how accurate he is dude okay like if
okay if you guys if you guys are excited
to see Aquaman in the Justice League
movie just type in yes in the chat just
type yes because I am very very excited
I'm very excited to see him um all right
mr. Murphy Deemer 48 Murph since century
is stronger than Superman Prime doesn't
that mean Goku would never have a chance
to beat him I don't know that's power
scaling and I don't really use power
scaling just because it's not you can't
really you can't take it as an absolute
it's a cool it's a fun way to for fans
to basically argue things but you can't
really you can't take it as an absolute
just because it's you know it's power
scaling you can make any character the
most powerful character in existence
when you use power scaling so um alright
uh Edward Howard thank you for getting
me in the comics I never read them until
I started watching your channel what do
you think about Black Panthers new plant
Oh new planet
I think it's cool like hey they're
having a new planet planet vast I'm
excited to see where that goes
I definitely hope it will like I think
Tallahassee coast is still going to be
writing it if you haven't been reading
Tallahassee Coates
Black Panther it's actually some of the
best Black Panther writing in recent
memory and I do not take that lightly
because Christopher priest Run was super
good but it's some of the best Black
Panther writing that I've seen in years
I'm really excited to see where it ends
up going I hope that he's gonna stay
onboard but I'm not a hundred cents sure
I haven't looked up who it is just
riding the new Marvel Legacy Black
Panther run um alright uh Graham hope
will you ever do more Rick and Morty
comics probably not I really couldn't
get into the comics the comics were you
know it was fun to do the omega by
omegan level thing but that'll probably
be the extent of it I couldn't really
get into the comics too much so I kind
of left him behind um god I really
should have made myself look good for
this for this thing and look like I'm
kind of a
okay I have a question for you guys
alright I have a question for you guys
alright because you guys asked me these
verses videos all the time alright who
do you think would win
Superman 1 million or dr. Manhattan who
do you think who do you think would win
I'm kind of curious some people are like
Manhattan maybe even think about it it
just typed in Manhattan I guarantee
that's what's gonna happen oh wow we
just got a huge dump of super chats
alright um let's see
Scottie Rob can you do a how much
explain video on the worst villain group
ever section 8 oh dude it's funny
because I have that script sitting
around and it's just waiting um dude
dude the section hate was I know exactly
who you're talking about
I had my writer Sean write a script for
that um yes I I have that I have that in
the works yes it's on its way
section 8 was a terrible super super
event they were they were they were
terrible all right Blake Perry um in the
event that World War Hulk and claw got
in a fight who would win World War Hulk
hands down
all right oh that's good Wow Scotty
robbed another five bucks thank you can
you do a comics displaying video oh yeah
yes about Section eight okay cool I'm
trying to get caught up on these super
chats so and then we have one more I
think okay
uh hey Rob thanks for all your videos
you got me into reading comics and could
you do Goku for an omega-level yes
that's definitely coming up and that's
want you to get with Danny like Omega
beyond Omega level Goku with the he has
something called ultra sense or
something like that
no idea what it is like no no clue what
ultra sense is I have I have no idea
okay let's look at the responses so
Manhattan Manhattan Manhattan super
super Manhattan somebody had just be a
smart aleck super Manhattan New Jersey
would win 1 million dr. Manhattan it
seems kind of split I don't know who
would win I just think it would be kind
of interesting how will silver how will
infinity war work without Silver Surfer
I think they're replacing with division
I have no idea I don't I don't know who
do you think would win in an all-out
fight century or versus all-out Goku I
think would
against the century yeah that's that
that I think would end up in a point Wow
Rafi asked that question three times
okay um let's see uh what do I think of
the Black Panther I love the Black
Panther trailer I thought it was pretty
amazing
it's definitely one of the best trailers
out there I'm super hype somebody that's
a question already super hyped about it
okay venom versus Ivanov okay we already
did it in versus Superman I'm not behind
on questions am i at least I don't I
don't think I am um Rick and Morty and
Marvel or DC if he had to choose Marvel
just because I feel like they would fit
in with Deadpool I feel like they would
fit in perfectly with Deadpool um
alright Rob are you gonna do more
rundown episodes they are by far my
favorite vids on your channel yes I'm
actually working on revamping the
concept of The Rundown because some
YouTube channel and I'm not gonna say
who tried to steal my idea of the
rundown and make a video make a YouTube
channel on it and I'm getting ready to
steal it back uh let's see Saitama vs.
anyone it's like he's one punch man he
beats everybody in one punch
it's definitely Saitama I don't know I
don't know who else it would be besides
him
alright alright EEE kripp I guess it is
can you review invincible the story is
awesome and one of my favorites plus
it's about to end I try to do invincible
um the first volume and couldn't really
get into it wow we just had like a ton
of super chance I just dropped um I try
to get into it and I couldn't really I
couldn't really dig it too much um I
think it's okay but I couldn't really
couldn't really get behind it holy cow
Jesus uh Wow okay we have we decided to
find a super chat's drop in here holy
cow alright I'm gonna try to answer
these it's best I can
uh let's see okay uh Dan boats Wharf
could you make a musical about any hero
who wouldn't oh if I could make a
musical about any hero who would it be I
would write a musical about Squirrel
Girl
I do what about Deadpool I think it'd be
amazing Evan well in
thank you for five bucks all right we
did a crib that was invincible okay so
that is for some reason it's doubling up
on super chats which is kind of weird um
okay wakeboarder 19 are you coming to
the west coast and what is your vape
setup I'll probably I don't know when
I'll come to the west coast again I like
coming to the west coast I definitely
love me in there um my face set up is on
Twitter I'll post it on Twitter if
you're interested in it just because I
know there are some people here in the
chat who are of a younger age and don't
need to know about that kind of stuff so
um let's see uh let's see composite
Barry Allen versus Batman infinite prep
time bloodless no morals well Batman of
course just ask anyone who's a Batman
fan I would say I would say the flash
easily um let's see uh could you do DC's
justice oh you're talking about the
world's greatest superheroes I
definitely want to do that like I want
to do that when Justice League comes out
um I interrupted your how much explained
binge
I read your binge on the middle of my
own videos more ultimate Thor 3d print
rings no I mean out that was the only
ultimate Thor thing I wanted to do and I
only did that just to get ready for
unworthy Thor but not unaware the Thor
the the four video where he were the
ultimate hammer drops on earth that was
the only one that I plan on doing that
with all right Professor Green ever
heard of the channel dope spill comics
you two would make an awesome team all
right
unbeatable Squirrel Girl beetle Squirrel
Girl sucks I don't know about that I
mean I guess kind of not really I mean
she's got her own thing um what's your
comic book you know my favorite comic
book that I own my favorite comic book
that I own is a comic that I got signed
during my first Meetup and it's an a
force comic which I loved
I loved Secret Wars loved a force was to
get worse 2015 a try and um no I um I
had that autographed or had a signed by
all the fans who showed up at the meetup
so uh yeah that one I definitely that
one I definitely enjoy is probably the
most valuable one that I own so Saitama
is
saitama's omega-level yes yes he is
okay these things are these things are
like the comments are coming in and just
like a bun
at one time um all right uh Rob how do
you watched it bent in and if so can you
do a Omega or beyond Omega a little
never watch bent in don't even know what
been ten is I have no clue
um let's see can you do New Mutants
demon bear saga probably not I mean
that's old-school it's far the oldest
unwilling to go back is probably hmm the
farthest that I'm willing to go back is
probably the mutant massacre maybe and
that would be about it
um let's see okay uh I don't miss a
super chat tonight okay cool
Steven Harris if Deadpool was to start
and a remake of boys in the hood who
would Deadpool play he would play Cuba
Gooding jr. 's character oh man um Rob
who would you cast as Darkseid in the
DCU
um to play the voice probably James Earl
Jones um cuz I think he got to be a
digital character whose voice who's
voiced and I think James Earl Jones
would be a really good one either that
of the guy who was in Pontypool and
played the radio guy came over what his
name is if you guys do go check out
pontypool that that is amazing like that
that show is amazing her movies amazing
turn on slow mode slow mode is oh no
maybe slow mode is not on I can't
remember how to turn on slow mode IQ
ever had to turn it on I can't remember
no those are emojis okay Rob are there
any male star sapphires Hal Jordan was a
star sapphire at one point I don't think
anybody else was know was a John Stewart
a star sapphire somebody somebody let me
know um I think maybe he is uh let's see
would you ever cover the Wildstorm
comics and if not can you give me a
quick rundown of them because they look
interesting I've never read Wildstorm so
I've I mean I wouldn't say that I
wouldn't cover them but I've never read
them so I couldn't even begin to give
you an explanation on him I know that
Wildstorm was founded by Jim Lee and I
know it was isolated from the rest of
the DC continuity and was rolled in
during new
- but I never never read it so I have no
idea um let's see
the guy who played General Zod would be
good Michael Shannon yeah I mean he
probably be a good dark side but he was
already General Zod so well then he
became doomsday like a nasty screwed up
looking doomsday um do an episode as
Morty no I'm not gonna make one of my
videos as Morty that would become really
annoying really fast so no I'm not gonna
do that Connor Nagle ten dollars Thank
You Connor Nagle I appreciate that um
okay uh the reality of bipolarity what a
name silo from heroes versus rogue from
x-men Wow
dude that is a good one um probably
Sylar uh I'd say probably Sylar I'd say
it would probably definitely be him just
because he would just pin her in place
and then you know do his thing and take
her book mm-hmm
you think I eat brains Claire that's
disgusting let's see do you I think
hunter zolomon will appear in rebirth
probably not I don't think so we would
if he was he would have appeared more in
the flash so um let's see uh can we get
a video on Phantom Stranger maybe
there's an Omega level thing but I mean
there's not really a reason to cover him
as a character because we don't know
anything about like we don't know his
origin we don't know he's just there you
know he's just this guy who's there and
nobody knows anything about him he just
lives up to his namesake so um let's see
uh yeah it's me Matt 89 Rob when are you
going to get into audio audio books
audio comics I would buy them also a
Vader versus gambit Darth Vader um I'm
actually actually just finished
recording an audio book for a part of
Treasure Island so um that's I'm still
kind of trying to figure that out I want
to make I want to move it in my new
house and get like a soundproof room and
then then worry about that Rob why are
you so awesome I don't think I'm that
awesome but I appreciate it I'm glad you
I'm glad you dig it I'm loving these
live interactions on your channel would
you ever consider doing Marvel DC movie
watch alongs on twitch or youtube I
would love to you but as far as I'm
aware that's no note here Tori when it
comes to copyright like you'll get your
channel shut down so I would love to do
that but that's that's not the
not possible I'd get my channel closed
and I don't I don't I don't want to do
that
Captain America Steve Rogers with a
Green Lantern ring versus Hulk with a
Red Lantern ring who would win Hulk he
would just be unbridled rage I mean
there's there he'd be a force of nature
he'd be a multiversal entity so um Rob
what tone themes should the Nightwing
movie take to be most successful a blend
between the darkness of Batman and the
hope of Superman is what it would take
it have to be this happy medium
Nightwing himself would have to be a guy
who is hopeful living in a city that's
darkened draaby because what Haven is
just like this really terrible place all
right those of you guys who were doing
super chats I appreciate it
give me one second let me grab some of
these questions from people who were not
super chatting so they don't they don't
feel left out um Rob you are great when
are you coming to Houston bro that comes
from Zachary none uh I don't know if
I'll be coming to Houston but I'll be
coming to Texas to hang out with trailer
Drake's sometime soon
I need to get with him again and go hang
out one of the things that I've noticed
that you guys love is seeing youtubers
meet over yay like you guys get so
excited about that and it's so funny to
me because back before I got into
YouTube I used to watch Hutchins
seananners all the time and I still do I
just don't watch their content every day
well CNN there's not so much because he
uploads like a video a week or something
like that now um but I still watch hutch
i watch his videos and it's live streams
which if you guys don't know who hutch
is you guys need to go check out his
channel Shaun zero 72 a super cool guy
he does philosophy and stuff like that
which I love I love talking about stuff
like that
I've always want to be on camp hutch but
I don't know I don't know of that ever
be possible but um but I used to like
they would cross over and they would
hang out when they were in in machinery
spawn and I was so excited about two
favorite youtubers hanging out and
working together and doing stuff um you
guys love crossovers yes you do can you
do the new punisher platoon comics um as
far as i know it's just the when it
finishes sure but i don't know how long
it'll be
I know Marvel is doing some of them
twice a month and they're doing some of
them once a month and so I don't know if
that's gonna be one that comes out twice
a month so let's see can you do the
story where superboy-prime tortures mr.
M I don't know about that story please
do a beta ray bill for Omega level
video please um I may end up doing that
like the weekend before Thor comes out
actually uh well no my guys already I
think he's already sending it to me for
this weekend um what is the one that I
have coming out this weekend I'm gonna
voice when it is this comes out this
weekend which one did I ask him about
hold on one second guys you guys will
get like a sneak preview of the one
that's that's coming out this weekend uh
maybe if I can pull up Facebook pull up
my chat
I'll even think Ryan's in here but I
don't remember which one it was that I
asked him to do Ryan uh let's see
Oh yellow lanterns Superman that's the
Omega Beyond Omega level coming out this
weekend so next week it'll be four and
then we might do beta ray bill after
that so I'm not sure have I read The
Runaways not in a long time not in quite
some time I'm confused on dark nights
metal does it take place before or after
the current individual runs it ties in
um but that is that is kind of the weird
thing the tie ends do get a little
strange in terms of how they fit into
continuity so at one point they said The
Phantom Stranger is Judas Iscariot just
wanted to share that Jason shifflett
thank you Jason I caught that just in
the nick of time okay uh let's see comic
Goblin Rob what are your thoughts on the
night alibiing Rorschach and Doomsday
Clock it makes sense to me I don't think
that's what happened though I do not
think that's what took place I think
that flashpoint happened I think that
Rorschach was resurrected by the events
of Flashpoint
I think that the events of the original
Watchmen so happened but I think dr.
Manhattan was not affected or he saw the
events of Flashpoint take place and
became curious about the DC universe I
think that's how he's involved
I think it's legitimately Rorschach I
think it's actually him who's alive um
James Hidalgo five bucks thank you would
you do a character explain on the
slingers I've been reading Ben Riley the
Scarlet Spider and saw that they make an
appearance I don't even know who they
are
I haven't read Ben Riley Scarlet Spider
yet I need to but I am not by any means
caught up so I should probably check
that out because I don't know who the
slingers are let's see rob is there a
chance I could be part of the Rob core
you already are if you're in the chat if
you're sub to my channel you're part of
the
four so even if you're not sub to the
channel you're part of the rod Court
what do you want to be or not so let's
see what female superhero would you most
like to eat a pork chop off what what
how a girl that's always right answer
Dean Boat Wharf yo Dawg you ever smoked
some of that good look at this guys
question you ever smoked some of that
good good good wacky tabacky like you
ever kicked Spidey out of the bed and
take Mary Jane to the smoke zone my god
def oh not a cop by the way the
questions you guys asked crack me up
sometimes um yes I'm oh I want to cover
the flash by Geoff Johns uh no I don't
do that that's not my thing so that's
that's not that's not my thing
when when will I cover the identity of
mr. oz when the story finishes cuz right
now the odds effect is still going on as
far as I'm aware please read JLA act of
God also using Batman of Japan and Jaime
Reyes Blue Beetle as examples what are
the kind of Japanese superhero inspired
characters would you like to see in DC
and Marvel um like Green Lantern I think
would be kind of cool something on those
lines um I don't know I mean the whole
idea of new Superman you know like a
Superman from China and the whole you
know that part of the world being able
to see like superheroes represented
there I think is actually super cool and
I'm really interested to see how that
goes what are you expecting wanting in
darkseid's eventual return come December
Darkseid vs. Manhattan also a mega level
video on Darkseid definitely um no idea
I mean I'm expecting him to to launch an
attack against the Justice League that's
kind of what I'm expecting to come out
of it so uh Rob what's your opinion on
Alan Scott the Green Lantern love Alan
Scott the Green Lantern definitely one
of the most important Green Lantern's
ever created because he was the original
and he set the standard for all the
Green Lantern's that came later so um he
is pretty solid he's definitely one of
my favorites
Paul Luna Salinas what do you think of
rebirth Nightwing went so far it's my
favorite what is yours loved it I
absolutely loved it
I haven't finished blockbuster yet but I
do absolutely love it
um I think the flash is my favorite
coming out of rebirth so far you know
it's the best thing coming out of do you
see rebirth I think the flash is
probably my favorite so far it's it's
pretty solid and definitely enjoyable do
you think DC dropped the ball with
doomsday and Denver Superman I believe
they should have done bizarro
I think they totally screwed up with
doomsday I think it was too big too fast
I think that's the biggest problem with
Batman vs Superman is I think they
basically tried to make it out to be a
mini Avengers esque movie and they just
did way too much with it
then a lot of that stuff dues they could
have been saved for a later date the
death of Superman definitely should have
been safe for a later date because he's
now he's already died what are they
gonna do kill him again at that point he
becomes the most inept superhero ever so
um I mean you you I think they really I
think they torched a lot of possible
stories in the future by just doing too
much too fast
that being said there are still a lot of
other stories they could do flashpoint
different things like that which
supposedly they're supposed to be the
great big huge thing but but I don't
know um let's see uh well what did you
think of that last issue of amazing
spider-man haven't read it um I guess I
should but I haven't seen it yet uh
beyond omega-level super-goof no idea
who that is
um let's see alright a couple more
questions guys and I'm gonna bounce off
here do you think Vegeta could be
stronger than Goku um I would like to
think so
I mean there were brief moments where he
was but I don't know I mean not
consistently across the board always
stronger it was never go ku keeping up
with Aegina it was always with you -
keeping up with Goku but Vegeta is my
favorite character in all of Dragonball
I absolutely love his character because
he's the prince of sins you know I love
that man like in me and the the English
dub when he talked about how he became
Super Saiyan for the first time he was
like the Prince of sight what is it he
was like I am the Prince of all Saiyans
once again I guess it's do those little
promos they used to cut at the beginning
of Toonami were so cool when they were
doing like Dragonball do those things
were so amazing um you know I'm gonna go
watch them Dragonball as soon as I get
done with this watch them Dragon Ball Z
you're gonna get all caught up again uh
let's see I have a question for you Rob
if the Hulk had a Red Lantern ring and
was able to use the wars hammer would
anyone be able to stop him nope he would
destroy the universe um let's see
spongebob is omega-level right Oh
he's just a guy with with Squarepants
that lives at the bottom of the sea so
um let's see hey Rob what are your
thoughts on Rick and yeah I couldn't get
into Rick and Morty too much the show's
interesting but it depends on the
episode sometimes it's my kind of humor
and sometimes it's not so let's see what
are your thoughts on the revelation of
the mr. Oz identity greetings from
Argentina Wow Matias Dan van der fur I
think it's not your pronouncement I
apologize advice if I screw that up I am
I think the identity reveal is kind of
cool I think that I hope it's a red
herring
I hope there's something else going on
but if that's who it really is then I
can work with that I mean that's that's
cool you know I'm on the interest
regardless of how the reveal went I
would be excited to see where it goes so
um let's see uh could you do an Omega
level beyond Omega level video on saint
of killers that's from DC right i have
no idea who that is
I think it's from DC but I've heard the
name but I don't know that sounds like a
cool name though um let's see it's
Franklin B Omega or beyond Omega level
beyond Omega level um let's see please
Wow please cover the Punisher versus
Dredd and I've never read that beyond
Omegan level Phantom Stranger um yeah I
mean that's definitely a video that I
would make there's a lot of a lot of
characters that we haven't done yet that
we would definitely do videos on
somewhere along the line let's see hey
Rob it's oh it's puse what's up yeah I'm
having a pretty good day I will be on
destiny to probably hear in about 20 or
30 minutes and covering the weekly stuff
and then I'll be off for the rest of the
week so um let's see Rob have you
checked out Batman White Knight
six-issue run and issue 1 is amazing not
yet um I think it's gonna be pretty
solid I think it's gonna be pretty
awesome
so idubbbz with a pink Lantern ring
versus rice gum Hulk idubbbz man those
counting cop videos man contin cop kills
channels it is it's not counting cops
hilarious to me I hope I don't ever end
up on one so and if I do I hope it's
like a parody like not a serious one uh
but yeah it's idubbbz is pretty
interesting his videos are pretty
entertaining so um let's see Rob do I
read digital or print I read digital
every time I get my comics the only time
I ever buy print is if it's a very
comic or something interesting like I
bought the print versions of like
Dawnbreaker I bought the the print
versions of like Red Death and the print
versions of Dark Knight metal number 1
but those are just for me to have I
don't really plan on selling them or
anything like that um let's see uh
beyond Omega level Stanley
uh probably I think they'd be kind of an
interesting one to do on a Stanley
Stanley one it would be just my luck
though that I would do it on a day that
Stanley passes away not realizing he had
passed and I would just be like really
you know but know what I want to do who
rob I should try ASMR just saying I
thought about doing that at one point do
you like an ASMR channel um no idea what
I would say I have no idea what I would
do just like read stuff like read the
dictionary I have no idea rob reads the
dictionary um let's see yeah uh Kirkland
Follis will you be at it will I be
attending Denver Comic Con 2010 a team
now that I've moved to Colorado and
maybe do a panel never really planned on
it I'm definitely cutting down on a
number of panels that I go to the number
of cons I go to you just because of the
fact that as much as I love meeting up
with fans between buying this house and
just trying to get everything organized
and settled um it's not gonna leave a
whole lot of room for me to go on a
whole bunch of trips with the production
studio we're launching out here with
what we're doing on the eligible monster
and colors explain and the other
ventures I'm branching off into you I'm
not gonna leave a whole lot of time for
me to go to a whole lot of cons so I'm
probably gonna have to be a little you
know you know be a little uh I guess
slim on how I do this you know a little
little picky I guess Michael Wood is
Klaw the hoax Hulk the most powerful of
banners alternate personalities no that
is not that's not the most powerful I
would say world war hulk is the most
powerful followed by maestro hulk okay
guys one more question then we're gonna
bounce off here a Rob first on a first
Super on YouTube ever thank you Joe B
would you cover the Justice League Power
Rangers crossover and blooms run on
rangers period while listening to MMPR
intro on loop Mighty Morphin Power
Rangers in blue no one that intro would
get my getting a copyright copyright
claim and two I never got into the Power
Rangers comics I tried to check him out
couldn't really get into it maybe
that'll change maybe I'll read him in a
you know next year and absolutely love
him but with my state of mind at the
moment I couldn't really get into it too
much I
guys I'm gonna bounce off here thanks
for coming out everybody thanks for
showing up we got 1,100 folks in our
live stream today which is pretty solid
uh yeah thanks for coming out guys it
was awesome having you here and
answering some questions we might turn
this into a thing where I do it a couple
times a week and you know just throw out
questions and throw out answers or the
questions you guys have but um anyway uh
yeah so I'm gonna bounce off here and
that will catch you all later peace